we're sharing our favorite healthy
noodle recipes because
you know i think that my number one
favorite food on planet earth
without a doubt is pasta yeah maybe
right under pizza but pasta is right
there for
carbs and cheese it's all the same thing
my metabolism
is asleep at the switch it's like a
drunk sloth it's just
not available to me my metabolism is an
active senior
you know it's just taking it easy well
you said something in the break that i
really loved because i'm a fluctuator i
have fluctuated my whole life
well i think it's so important because i
have fluctuated big swings you know like
i just said
50 pounds and i just recently saw a
picture of my heaviest which was like
250 something
and i looked at it and i first i felt
such disdain and i thought
no i've got to love myself there i've
got to love myself at my weakest or at
my worst
if i want to be anywhere else so i just
made peace and apologize to that person
and
i thought that was so powerful to do i
have to tell you
i really think that that is wise and
caring
so i had to tell everyone because i
think we tend to look at ourselves and
be like don't go there you don't want to
be this person and it's like no
love that person you don't have to stay
there and be stuck but
love love that person and learn which is
why we're trying to find new ways to
stay healthy right
so what i learned was i am the biggest
i should be their spokesperson this
noodle is made out of chickpeas now i'm
just gonna be honest if you're
eating gluten-free you are not
necessarily eating the lightest and the
healthiest
a lot of it is made with a lot of
bloating rice products
so chickpea is a really healthy
alternative for your body and the way it
can digest
i love chickpea it's like a garbanzo
bean that's a chickpea right and your
body processes it very different than a
rice product your body processes that
my body probably i love the chickpeas
okay so i love this pasta and of course
my favorite food is macaroni and cheese
so it's not surprising to me
that i grew up loving pesto because
that is basically like almost foodie mac
and cheese it's
so delicious too and it's so easy to
make i
love it so i'm going to show you with
this chickpea noodle
um also when your body is trying to
process like a white flour
and a dairy it's going to town it's in
like a boxing match for its life but if
you've got
chickpea noodles and then a little dairy
in the parmesan cheese of a pesto
you're not layering so many things that
your body has to do
so we're gonna take four bunches of
basil uh
a quarter cup of pine nuts the recipe
usually calls for about
three cloves of garlic i go four i would
go five i love it great
and then you have about a cup of
parmesan
cheese there she is now i put a little
olive oil in but one of the best things
to do with your olive oil is actually
emulsify it
while you're blending
yay so this is when you want to pour in
your olive oil
that changes the texture right
[Music]
there you go look at how gorgeous that
is
for how bright it is
i can smell the basil from here
absolutely it's so gorgeous
um this has a really bright beautiful
green color um this is fun watching you
to do this either in the kitchen
anyway all right so then
it's just my hand
oh yummy look at this
isn't this beautiful look at this
beautiful bright
green gorgeous pasta i mean it's
chickpea
but it's chickpea and look at how well
that these noodles hold this
i happen to love fusilli because it
holds all the sauce especially with
something like a pesto is that the shape
of the noodle fusilli
for sealy wow i didn't know that yeah
all right
can i taste it now drew yes absolutely
now chickpea and pesto yes this is
chickpea
with pesto now the other thing
that i want to say to all the vegans out
there because i grew up vegetarian
oh my god i can't even speak right now
another alternative to this that i
really love
is you can use a thing called
nutritional yeast now although it's the
most disgusting culinary term
yeah could we rebrand that and i know i
mean it's just use they could do
it's the yeast they could do
it's so true so now this actually
functions in texture and taste
like cheese and it has nine different
amino acids
and it is my favorite alternative for a
vegan pesto or
if you're just trying to lose weight or
clean your system out or detox a little
bit
one of the best ways to be honest is to
get rid of dairy for a little bit
so this way you don't have to give up
all the pleasure
you're eating it raw and i just want to
try it i've been dying to try
nutritional yeast so let me like this
uh hold on
it's not parmesan but it's not bad right
did you like the taste of this pasta
this pasta
is so crazy delicious drew it is so
fresh with the basil
and bright it was made with this shut up
was it really did you do the switcheroo
on ross matthews
isn't that incredible okay by itself i
don't know on the bus
i'm i'm i'm all down with yeast it's
just
an amazing way to indulge
and eat the food that is delicious and
doesn't taste like diet food but it is
going into your body
as if you are eating something so good
for it so we went noodle to noodle
mm-hmm uh i was impressed with your
noodle
yeah i was pretty impressed with your
noodle too all right
well that's you know why we're smart
because we use our noodles
we noodled on it well thank you for
noodling on it with me ross